you know i you know used some music with
bad words and just
what had some things that were not that
good of an influence so i just want to
also apologize for that and hopefully
moving forward my intention is to not do
any of those things i try not to cuss
even on a daily basis but it's bad it's
a bad habit
try not to be a bad you know example but
especially when i have i have over a
billion views on my youtube channel so
like i've done a lot of things in the
past that i probably shouldn't have and
i hope you know i i am apologizing for
it and hopefully you know you guys
don't hold any of that against me and
moving forward i only want to do good
things
a few days ago a brother known as faze
apex online posted this picture right
here
and as we know the internet went wild so
let's take a look at how people
responded and islam has been attacked so
as you guys may or may not have seen
face apex posted a picture on instagram
of him at mecca and wrote an amazing
caption in his caption he pretty much
said how important islam is but the
comments were insane look at this coming
that is a religion
jesus is the only true
oh and he keeps going a bunch of lost
souls
don't call an islamic a terrorist even
though they preach that in mosques and
it goes on and on and on y'all worship a
cube imagine praising that but no matter
how many people attack islam it doesn't
change the fact that it's the truth
alhamdulillah
there's no there's no denying that
but man what a shame people are just
unapologetically uh i guess fearless in
terms of showing everyone that they're
muslim especially being a public figure
and this is the response that they get
from the internet
yeah subhanallah i mean islamophobia is
uh running rampant unfortunately and
this type of bigotry is actually more
common than we would like it to be it's
something that's been propagated by the
media and by islamophobes people like
sam harris people like tommy robbins and
they've been at it for a long time but
alhamdulillah islam continues to grow
and to spread and we see it with
beautiful brothers like him allah bless
him who as you said are unapologetically
muslim unapologetically muslim as we all
should be alhamdulillah as we aim to be
on this channel
a lot of people are new to our channel
so if you're new and you have no idea
about islam check out that playlist that
i'm going to post right now called new
to islam but for any of you that uh had
a feeling this was coming i did too
because six months ago this is what
happened also i want to also just say
you know in the past i've made a lot of
videos that i'm not too happy or proud
about you know anymore when i was
younger i made some mistakes that i
would try not to make today i used to
curse a lot of my videos you said you
know make videos reacting to things
where i'd kind of make fun of
people not like make fun of people like
how they look and stuff like but you
know just joke around about like meme
videos and stuff and like you know i you
know use some music with bad words and
just
what had some things that were not that
good of an influence so i just want to
also apologize for that and hopefully
moving forward my intention is to not do
any of those things i try not to cuss
even on a daily basis but it's bad it's
a bad habit
try not to be a bad you know example but
especially when i have i have over a
billion views on my youtube channel so
like i've done a lot of things in the
past that i probably shouldn't have and
i hope you know i i am apologizing for
it and hopefully you know you guys
don't hold any of that against me and
moving forward i only want to do good
things on this channel and good you know
make fun videos still and all that but
you know it doesn't need we don't need a
cuss we don't want to make fun of people
don't need to use bad music anything
like that so just want to spread
positivity and good vibes all right and
subhanallah 1 billion views bro even
before when you wanted to square up with
your homie you would say 1v1 me on rust
even before that
faze apex the owner and founder of faze
clan was out here making content and
mashallah today
knowing the backlash you would get
because don't think that he didn't know
this would happen potentially he still
posted that picture and he's been
yeah masha allah may allah bless him and
bro just
it warms my heart to see a brother like
that because profane gets to people man
a lot of the time unfortunately when
brothers even muslim brothers especially
muslim brothers when they get famous man
everything goes man the money gets to
them the fame gets them the fortune gets
them everything gets to them and the
test of abundance a lot of the time is a
lot more difficult than the test of
scarcity and may allah bless the brother
because allah has guided him and he has
accepted it masha'allah you could see it
and you can hear in what he's saying and
how he's saying it but he's mentioning
the the wrong that he did he's a he's
owning up to it he's apologizing he's
mentioning intentions as well
all very islamic things
may allah bless him bro and you know
this kind of bigotry this kind of um
islamophobia that we see in the comments
is is nothing new it's honestly it's
something that unfortunately has been
going on for a long long time in the
west and it's something we muslims
unfortunately have gotten used to but
alhamdulillah you know it allows us to
learn our religion more to spread our
religion more and for every
misconception that people that somebody
has is um another step towards them
coming to islam because once they clear
that misconception if they're sincere
they will eventually enter islam as
we've seen a lot ever since even you
know september 11 for example a lot of
people converted after that event so
imagine how many people could convert
just from their brother's post when they
learn about what hajj is what mecca is
what umrah is and what islam is as a
whole
bro and how many people are just they'll
show that they're muslim but they're
kind of like shy about it you know what
i mean this man made an active call to
dao when i read it out right now he
wrote no blessing in life compares to
the blessing of being a muslim
nothing gives you more peace and purpose
in this world insha allah we will all be
reunited together
in the next life in the highest levels
of paradise i mean he continues i highly
encourage anyone who has any interest or
feels that they are missing
a purpose in life to look into islam
may god
guide us all to the best for us in this
life
and in the next subhanallah like that
was so
beautiful and eloquent but it was
it was subtle but it wasn't it was an
active call to islam no matter what
anyone says and that's something you
don't see today bro
yeah subhan allah
very very very well worded masha allah
and i'm see this is this is i think the
sign of a very sincere muslim who
actually cares for the well-beings of
others because a lot of the time they're
like i have my peace i found my peace i
found my truth but what he did what he
you know as muslims should do is he said
this is the truth if you're missing
something this is what it is you know in
a very respectful and in in in kind
manner very inviting
which is you know the son of the prophet
so subhanallah bro everyone watching
this video share this video and share
allah send it to faze apex and let's get
the brother on the three muslims podcast
insha'allah to do an interview with him
about his journey and him coming back to
islam i think that would be uh
phenomenal inshallah and when i say come
back i don't mean he left it's not for
allah it's just everyone in including
myself and if i go on this journey where
we're born to islam yeah we're muslim or
arab or whatever i mean he's not otto
but you know what i mean and then we get
to the point where it's like we live in
the west we do some dumb things and we
come back alhamdulillah by the
way
bro i think that's a high note we ended
up once again for anyone that made it
this far and it's actually sincere in
turning your life to the next level and
really leveling up because you feel like
you're missing something trust me i i
swear to god i'm not going to say well
light because you probably don't know
what that is but
god is my witness i swear to god this is
the truth don't believe me check out our
videos that's why we started this whole
youtube channel in the first place new
to islam is the playlist that i want you
to go through and trust me it will be
worth it insha allah insha allah one
last thing i want to add to the
islamophobes out there
bring any argument you have anything
bring whatever you want and challenge us
with it and by allah by allah by the end
of the discussion you will have nothing
left and you will have nothing except to
admit the fact that islam is the truth
and there is nothing that muslims will
shy away from and there's nothing we
can't answer about in our religion
alhamdulillah
if you guys made it this far comment
down below
and with that being s
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]